a squirrel is running across the road at
12 feet per second it needs to run nine
feet to get across the road how long
will it take the squirrel to run nine
feet round your round to the nearest
hundredth of a second fair enough a car
is 50 feet away from the squirrel okay
this this is a high stakes word problem
driving toward it at a speed of 100 feet
per second how long will it take the car
to drive 50 feet around to the nearest
hundredth of a second
will the squirrel make it nine feet
across the road before the car gets
there so this definitely is high stakes
at least for the squirrel so let's
answer the first question let's figure
out how long will it take the squirrel
to run nine feet
so let's think about it the squirrel let
me write squirrel
squirrel right over here
the squirrel
so the squirrel's got to go nine
nine feet and we have we want to figure
out how many seconds it's going to take
so what would we would we divide or
multiply this by 12. well to think about
that you could think about the units
where we want to get an answer in terms
of seconds we want to figure out time so
it'd be great if we could multiply this
times seconds
seconds per
seconds per foot then the feet will
cancel out and i'll be left with seconds
now right over here we're told that the
squirrel can run at 12 feet per second
but we want seconds per foot so the
squirrel every second so they go 12 feet
per second we then we could also say one
second per every 12 feet so let's write
it that way so it's essentially the
reciprocal of this because the units are
the reciprocal of this so it's one
second for every
12
12 feet notice all i did is i took this
information right over here 12 feet per
second and i wrote it a second per foot
12 feet for every one second one second
for every 12 feet
what's useful about this is this will
now give me the time it takes for the
squirrel in seconds
so the feet cancel out with the feet
and i am left with
9 times 1 12 which is 9
12
seconds
and 9 12 seconds is the same thing as 3
4 seconds which is the same thing as
0.75
seconds for the squirrel to cross the
street
now let's think about the car
so now let's think about the car that's
the exact same logic they tell us that
the car is 50 feet away so it's
the squirrel is trying to the squirrel
is trying to cross the road like that
and the car is 50 feet away coming in
like that and we want to figure out if
the squirrel will survive
so the car is 50 feet away
so it's 50
feet away we want to figure out the time
it'll take to travel at 50 feet
once again we would want it in seconds
so we would want seconds per feet
so we would want to multiply by seconds
per foot
seconds per foot they give us the speed
in feet per second 100 feet per second
and so we just have to realize that this
is 100 feet for every
one second or one one hundredth seconds
per feet this is once again just this
information
this information but we took the
reciprocal of it because we don't want
feet per second we want seconds per feet
and if we do that that cancels with that
and we're left with 50 over 100 seconds
so this is 50 over 100 is 0.50
seconds
and so now let's answer the question
this and death situation for the
squirrel
will the squirrel make it nine feet
across the road before the car gets
there
well it's going to take the squirrel
0.75 seconds to cross and it's going to
take the car only half a second so the
car is going to get to where the
squirrel is crossing before the squirrel
has a chance to get all the way across
the road so unfortunately for the
squirrel the answer is no